these are integers okay so these form
the sides of a right triangle but
they're not just any numbers you know
they're they're integral lengths okay
and these are the four ones that come up
the most often it's good to memorize
these three four five
okay Pythagorean triple five twelve
thirteen eight fifteen seventeen and
seven 24 25 so we know the Pythagorean
theorem okay we have a right triangle we
know that a squared plus B squared
equals C squared
but when we have these right triangles
here oftentimes what we'll do is we'll
get the three sides in such a way that
all the lengths will be integers and
they call that a Pythagorean triple now
there's more than just these four but
these ones are the most common that
you'll see okay or multiples of those so
let's go into some of the examples I'll
show you what I mean so if we have 6 X
and 10 at first glance we say hmm that
doesn't look like one of the Pythagorean
triples so we might just go right into
doing our Pythagorean theorem and that's
fine a squared plus B squared equals C
squared we'll still get the right answer
it just takes a little bit longer this
is just a shortcut but what we can do is
we can say well what number goes into 6
and 10 evenly just like you're reducing
a fraction like you're reducing six
tenths what would you reduce it to well
two goes in here three times two goes in
here five times hmm that looks like the
3 4 5 Pythagorean triple five is the
longest side so that's the hypotenuse
yep that's the hypotenuse across from
the right angle okay good so that means
that this side must be 4 right well
almost we doubled these so we want a
double four so this side is 8 okay so
you see how that works okay now on this
one we look at 24 and 45 say hmm what
goes into 24 and 45 3 right so if we
were to divide this by 3 we get 8 here
we would get 15 now it looks like this
one 8 15 17 so that means that 17 is the
hypotenuse across from the right angle
that's the longest side but since we
tripled these we want a triple 17 17
times 3 is 51
I'm going through it but as you do this
you'll get a little bit faster at it and
this will be a time saver so when you're
on that taking the AC T these come up a
lot so it can save you you know some
precious minutes that you can use to
solve other problems
okay last example here 130 50 you can
see they both end in zero okay so if I
was to divide these both by 10 we get 13
and 5 it looks like five 12 13
so that means this side must be 12 but
since we multiplied these by 10 we want
to multiply this one by 10 as well
120